- Up until recently, people worked
on their own in their rooms.
I mean curriculum development
was something we did
with maybe a colleague or two.
Maybe someone you went to
your credential program with.
- We engendered this
sense that this curriculum
was going to be owned by our teachers
rather than purchased for them.
- That conversation helping figure out
if they actually misunderstood it
or if they just answered wrong, you know?
- Like if they're just not
using the right terminology,
and their understanding is correct
but they're not talking
about it the right way.
- Ongoing professional
development is coming from
the communities of teachers
at Science collaborating,
making decisions about their own practice.
Teachers that are using the
curriculum all come together
able to share student work.
- If you look at all of
these, they're the same.
I mean these are a little more spread out,
but they're pretty much the same.
But her explanation on it shows
that she's at least understanding
that there's a difference
between three things.
- [Eric Lewis] They are able
to share some of their concerns
and questions about the curriculum,
but also do a lot of learning together.
- I wanted them to understand
that hot air is less dense.
I wanted them to actually see,
or at least in the explorer,
that hot air was less dense.
- They're able to make comments.
They're able to put something
into a discussion board.
They're able to share
some of the adaptations
that they've made that might take us
into a different direction.
We get to get our voices heard and you get
to really share information
and as a teacher,
really you want to share information.
- To have somebody who has been involved
in the development of the curriculum,
and that same person takes it
back to their own classroom
and tries it out, you
get really deep insight.
- We get to help the
curriculum along as we do it.
Collaboration days that we get to come to
are actually really beneficial.